how's gum rosebuds beautify we're
playing among the sleep you play as a
baby and it's a horror game what else
you need baby let's keep playing I love
it
what is this listen what there it is
again but in such like it's coming from
behind this door okay there must be a
way to open it
well I might miss it Shannon's like me
these are connected somehow
how about I put you in there and we'll
see if it works
no no no I was Teddy I was kidding me -
you sir are you too fat anyway maybe he
did require some sort of key oh and look
what I'm sayin we can use I don't know
what could we possibly use there you go
how's that key oh it is a key that
remind me then all right you sure you
don't want to go as well Teddy no less
is too bad all right let me let me spin
you I got I got my gun uh heavy Sam a
kitty
what's that why didn't it open we need
three of them let's find a way to open
it
um Marquis let's see nada niente Benny
Benny Benny III uh okay well what do I
know about life
maybe it's three memories have put three
memories in there no okay this is not
very nice in there just want to point
that out
mmm strange my click in here looks like
Teddy's necessary there you go teddy
hmm rather small but it looks like my
paws might fit okay well just shove it
in there maybe shove your hand right in
there really hard that's it
okay cuz I didn't see you click it
though alright now it's my chance it
seems like the memory you shared or
maybe if we can find more memories like
this might bring us to her okay looks
like we need three more that you're
right about that actually wonder where
this will take us hopefully not a bad
list
hey there with me teddy - I'll do my
best okay I guess now this folks is
gonna begin again what are you doing
alright that's weird
entering a new place mmm
is this called a silo phone cuz I always
forget what they're called in English
let me see if I can play it nope
I am as terrible in real life as in the
game [ __ ] Teddy you with me Teddy yeah
he's with me okay oh this doesn't look
too bad yeah
I hope the memory is close by come on
Teddy don't [ __ ] out on me show me your
real swag Oh G okay that swing looks fun
let's not try it
alright this looks like a memory oh it's
Ali Ali here come here
god of course of course you know what of
course
so that was one memory wasn't it it's a
pretty game I got it I got a going back
it's a it's cute
it's Bart it's so cute so cute well
that's pretty damn interesting too
it looks like another memory across that
bridge all right well I guess we just
have to find it then ha ha ha yeah [ __ ]
yeah I gotta get so much [ __ ] your
stare away when I go out Hauer
oh hello what are you doing here get out
in use tab all right we'll put an owl
there and apparently we need four one
two three four five yep what the [ __ ] is
wrong with this memory kid oh god he's
tricked that's adorable
all right we need to hug hug this [ __ ]
all right there we go
it's like guns no it's a fishing rod
Oh God let's eat Oh God Oh God
I'm hugging him teddy hug me teddy
Oh God Oh God
you better not let go my hugs man isn't
she
Shamu okay I got this
I've been trained I've been potty
trained baby I know how to do this
Shh oh that's me okay okay no we will
know
Oh God balls yeah damn it all right you
know what let's go here you know what
we're gonna have to crawl what's that
Oh God what is this place
there's no wow this is where I came from
that I really misinterpret that bad
okay well Yolo nice opposed maybe up to
slide can I go up the slide
nope I can't maybe over
let's check here I'm pretty strong for a
baby they should call me baby man wait
that yeah that didn't make sense
HiFi me I was not cheesy I don't even
need cheese oh god dad [ __ ] all right
you know what hug me Teddy thank you
I'm Way ahead of you text this oh god a
slender man isn't it I hope we're okay
cuz I'm not okay this is not my chic day
it's just not what is that least another
100 okay
first ones we're so easy to find but you
were really hard man oh god oh god hug
me hug man's game okay
don't hug man's game okay now in confuse
hey oh god its catcher Kat and kits
Katie okay yeah okay I'll save you you
praising all of you
come on Baha hi Katie no way you're free
now go tell the King about this and come
back with his men go all right we're
back here now
all right so we have four hours we need
eight I think not sure actually I'm
pretty
ow god that hurt okay what is that what
is all this sounds Teddy better hug me a
little bit
um it's harder than I thought you think
there's something here gives this stuff
over there and there's quite a lot of
owls to find but my stupidity defeats me
as always what if we climb here then oh
I bet I miss it last time come on here
we go
all right another bench Assassin's Creed
baby edition love it more
Slenderman picture what are you God ow I
found you I found you come here
fantastic okay it just spins night it's
a shut up trying to play a game here
baby
God rude that's supposed to be a hangman
or some [ __ ] oh god oh god what the [ __ ]
oh that Jerry
it's my bully from school I hate that
guy
you always take my toys yes it explains
everything alright let's just keep our
head down
what now up up keep it up alright here
we go
it's bound to be one up here let's go
down this freaky hellish line up fell
and doom and it's gonna be awesome
can I ride you though Madison you are
one creepy [ __ ] huh
don't judge me god damn you sexy [ __ ]
just cuz he's sexy and thinks he can
judge everyone alright so we need to get
this tree Rocking
get that out of the way can I possibly
do it on my own mind gosh everyone knows
a tire is stronger than my own hands
everyone maybe I need to swing it
actually never mind alright swing it
alright nailed it mr. owl now mr. owl
from the report of Sergeant parrots and
ball you're coming with us baby wait how
many was that ow [ __ ]
is that all of them I feel like we
missed one Oh God just sound what is it
coming friend hug me hug me teddy hug me
it is saving so I think we're done
don't you dare let go don't you dare let
go baby
god damn it Eddie I loved it so much I
loved his dumb ass Teddy you're my
favorite favorite of all celebrities yes
even more than Ryan Cranston I don't
even know who he is
all right yes flop it's actually a
phobia mine to put things in holes so
that really disgust me a little bit but
I'm just gonna have to go with it just
gonna have to go with the baby all right
here we go huh
Slendy man I know you're out there
douchebag Oh God
I hear some weird noises Teddy I don't
think this is safe doesn't what that I
knew gravity had something to do with
this
we better crawl come on yeah yeah
or baby he must be freaking out right
now hi Alice good times you know what my
shovel [ __ ] and you can't have it you
don't even have thumbs what are you
possibly gonna do with a shovel am i
holding it that's the greater question
actually
hey telekinesis every baby has it look
goddamn you shovel this is so glossy
good luck evil with your [ __ ] oh we
exited it alright hello
one more time but that's it another
memory
well rainbow
I love Oh finally we must be getting
closer
well it's a silo phone I am good at
thing hahaha all right say does change
that's awesome what's with these pipes
man girls humming reminds me of Bastion
you play that game
Oh low Frank sorry I can't help myself
we're back here we got another memory
we're off high five high five
a little bit a little how you doing
sweet don't judge don't again no one
likes Ian come on you're not my teddy I
have my teddy head guy I don't need you
your mother
yep well nice walking there sir teddy
wait wow she has to be so worried about
you what kind of drugs are you afraid
you and me will work this all out
together all right
I know they're gonna know the ropes by
now it's a rope oh I'll just put that in
there then fantastic let's close it ah
come on
and then what and it yep
bad Deb but yeah oh
then [ __ ] strong okay I got we need
two more
I didn't see that one
yes she sounds clearer no no Teddy you
better come with me Teddy yeah no time
to lose sight that's a good teddy
watch I said my own teddy whenever
you're ready you don't blow when I have
you come on in yet come on don't be the
Gumby neck wish I will do the blowing
Edgar special edition instead of this
guy damn it
alright it's pretty also so far that
we'll have to do it for that I hope you
enjoyed watching this episode thank you
for watching I do appreciate you being
here if it wasn't for you I wouldn't be
here
think about that for a moment go ahead
and leave a like if you enjoy watching
and very much appreciate it and I'll see
you tomorrow
within the episode stay awesome bros
this one's for you